okay so I think I know where that penis
hairstyle from the last airbender movie
probably came from now III didn't see it
in this episode but I I get a feeling
it's with this one character I could be
wrong
it's the princess character in this but
out of the picture I saw I will see oh
we're way to start so anyway this is
they finally make it to metric was
playing made me cry huh um finally get
to the North Pole in this episode was at
the waterbending master right the
waterbending master they finally get to
this place
oh good lardo is taking forever they
finally get there they find it it's a
great really cool layout eyesore reminds
me of like a level from Super Mario Bros
2 like this winter place it's made of
like ice and snow and stuff in it and
it's so cool you get to see the
waterbenders open the doors and close it
only the ways that waterbender can which
is great it's our concern when the Fire
Nation gets there because they can melt
that shit pretty fast but nevertheless
it's a it's a great layout of this place
it's made almost entirely out of snow
and ice um and that they get to this
place finally an finds a teacher and
they're all welcomed in they're all
welcome to live there and the King shows
his uh you know Sokka his daughter's
this princess character that you know he
instantly falls in love with and wants
to be with and everything seems he going
great they even have a waterbending
master who's got a training and then
Katara wants to be trained to I said
sorry no girls allowed
well shit just shit so we have that
going on uh and it's weird cuz I don't
like these plots because you just know
how they're going to end and this one
throws a few twists in there that makes
a little bit more interesting but it's
just you know come on girl power hey we
can do this too we know God but at the
same time it's some tribes and cultures
they just have bullshit traditions you
know and that's you know that's still
true
there's
many parts of the world where men can't
do certain things and women aren't
allowed to do certain things and it's
it's bullshit now you know is bullshit
whatever so I guess it's addressing that
is just as a story I find a little
boring but but they do some interesting
stuff with it what I like first I really
like that Aang stands up and says if
you're not gonna train her then I don't
want be trained by you either and I like
also that Katara stands up and says no
it's really important that you learn
this you need to learn this there's a
friggin comet coming you're the you're
the avatar you're the last one who can
do this you need to learn this and again
them showing much more responsibility
than the teacher if the teacher had any
thought I mean he would be like oh wait
this guy who's gonna be this loki is
gonna be our only hope for anything we
should please him
we should really really try and you know
maybe bend our traditions a little bit
so it's not that women are not allowed
to waterbend in this tribe it's that
they can only use it for healing which
is good yeah it's awesome that they can
do that but they can't do anything
beyond that so she goes to this this
part where they train they do
waterbending for Girls essentially night
I mean like little girls as well which
is kind of fire just come Angeles going
home uh you know it's already knowing
she's kind of behind but it you know
it's good to learn the healing aspect
too I you know I don't like it when it's
always like you know this person will
heal it Oh what they can't fight all
right things like fuck's wrong with
healing you are bringing people back to
life you're saving lives if anything is
much better than destroying a life you
know that there's no less strength than
either of them you both take great
respect or responsibility so um but
granted that I know what they're saying
that's usually you know goes to the
women like that's all they can do of
course that's bullshit so we have this
going on and she shares the story with
one the healers they're about about a
grandmother and how she used to be a
part of the tribe and that comes in
later obviously ends up saving
everything
what happens is that which I'm I like
this idea they came up with where the
salikus says well I thanks being taught
how to do this why doesn't a just teach
Katara and they're like yeah that's a
great idea and I'm like yeah that is a
great idea as far as I didn't tell you
ladies that's actually a really
wonderful idea uh and how come nobody
else in the town has thought of this
again I guess it's the culture like men
and women in this culture like oh that's
how we were raised whatever but none of
them ever did anything different like
that maybe I don't know I thought she
was going to go to the healing water
benders and then like they teach the
healing it's like all right enough of
that bullshit let's show how to actually
do some whipping and some fighting stuff
like they were secretly doing this um so
but nevertheless that they agreed to
this idea the teacher season says I can
never teach you again Aang I can teach
you guy who's going to save the world
but now I'm not going to show you how it
I don't know it's kind of stupid but
prejudiced it's bad ah
so finally you know Katara says no no
look look this is more important I'll
submit I'll be a good girl I won't you
know learn anymore how to use it as a
weapon and they want her to apologize
that she just clenches her fist says
fuck you man I'm going not I'm going
home but pretty much that I'm you want
to fight me come and fight me I'll be
outside which is I do what are you doing
you can't win this and she says I know I
just I had to do it which is a little
odd too but I guess maybe fall somewhere
under proving yourself or proving that
women can fight as I don't know it was
of a weird motivation to challenge him
to a fight but know what she does and
you know for someone who apparently has
not learned waterbending she's pretty
fucking good I mean like this fight that
they have I'm like how is she she's like
maybe one step under this incredible
master what what is this I need to learn
I need to learns that you should be
teaching half the people there so and so
they have this fight it's a cool fight
she
I think she gets bested in the end but
then he sees her necklace that he
recognized was the necklace I belong to
her grandmother and he was betrothed to
her but then she left cuz she didn't
have feelings for him and he realizes
I've been a douche and he decides to
teach her and that's pretty much where
it ends uh so oh and on top of that the
whole betrothing also ties into the
romance between Sokka and this princess
character who you know and again
everyone's always like what's with the
princess hating you and stuff like that
it's here it's justified there's a legit
king and he's ruling things and it's
like he has a daughter that that works
that that's totally legit I'll have a
problem here um so I mean so she's be
trove to someone else
Sokka finds out but she still can't lead
them on which is a little weird but it's
still cute it's a cute romance of course
it doesn't look like it's gonna stop
there I mean I'm sure they're gonna do
more with it um it pretty much ends with
her saying you know I think age runs off
so I'm sure it's gonna be more with that
uh but it was still good I'm glad they
finally got to this place um I was kind
of hoping like the chase aspect is great
and I actually don't mind it it keeps
going but you know at some point you're
gonna get a little tired of it you want
to reach their goal I was starting to
get a little tired of it and then they
reach there just in time they reached
their destination so I like that it is
good timing that they finally got to
this place uh and it ends with Aang and
Katara both learning the waterbending
from this master in one day he turns
around on all this tradition I I don't
know but it's still good it's good
because the character still stick up for
each other they still really hold their
values very close to them and they stand
up for what they believe is right and
they stand up for the friends and they
do it in circumstances we can understand
uh we can understand Aang saying if
you're not good train her you don't
train me that's a very mature thing to
do and her saying no it's more important
you can be trained I'll be left out
very mature thing to do but both of us
still trying to find what's the right
proper way to handle this you know how
can we still do what's ethical e right
you know because this is bullshit so
it's it's good it's still good episode I
loved seeing this this North Pole place
which which looks really great um so it
was a good episode and oh my god honey
we're almost done with the first season
I think we have two episodes here left
so it says a part 1 part 2 us I'll
probably just do that as one episode
again yeah for the next one if anything
to make up for the two or three the rest
this past week I didn't give you some
for two or three days and people burned
down buildings and shit so with their
firebending regardless ah I will see you
in that next episode until then take
care